[Musique]
tu veux que tu as encore rhodia cette
heure ci vivement que ça s'arrête celle
des pressions ça fait beaucoup trop
longtemps que ça dure
si tu te reprends pas immédiatement main
tu finir en hp comme sa grand-mère babet
j'ai 34 ans je fais le boulot tu as
voulu devenir écrivain tu t'es planté
savoir faire un constat d'échec parfois
site avait du talent ça serait
maintenant pensez être une psychopathe
dangereux que social et sophistiquée
qu'audacieuse féline féline
ça veut rien dire fait une c'est juste
une façon plaisir [ __ ] dont j'ai
besoin c'est que tu réagisses enfin
comporter comme une adulte ne prenez pas
de venir d'elle maman c'est comme pour
les toques cl colo faut que ça vienne de
l'intérieur vraiment que tu apprennes à
très conseillé de féminité une femme
doit savoir jouer de ses atouts
ça va pas du tout su rebondir un travail
olympio existe une retenue sur adjani
avec le fateh épouse
il ya un truc je supporte pas pesé sur
les fautes d'orthographe c'est
exactement pareil fautes grammaticales
il faut sur le pluriel et festivals
estivaux
[Musique]